nobody ever gets canceled for being too
woke so you can say the craziest thing
like men can have babies
and then nobody even though people are
thinking well that's kind of nuts nobody
will say it they'll just fall in line uh
yeah yeah exactly that's what I've
always thought mental babies sure I saw
a dude who was glowing yesterday you
know I mean it's and that's the problem
and it's totally insane cowardice yes it
is it's moral cowardice isn't it but
it's an intellectual cowardice and but
it also comes from a place of reality
that fear because they see people around
them literally getting canceled getting
shamed and abused and hounded out of
jobs I don't want it to happen to me